Ok.
The classic had an ism of membrane
is not the head an ism of new york
or london or paris or
cairo or wherever. But.
Full moon nights and the fruits of
your own vine. Delicious trees.
I mean the sister act.
Healthy living beautifully prepared
and presented vegetarian fact.
I think one talks of food
and lentils as being the food of
other non-meat eating culture
and i can assure you
that we eat well we home brew
and. And herbal teas herbal teas etc.
Tingle.
And and of course the dope smoking and
that and the mushrooms and things
and certainly in early
days of nimbin they.
That that was that the bout
that the sum total of any any.
Drug taking that that that i was aware of
and and i will say this that i grew up
or i lived in then been.
For those 17 years i have lived in
those and i and i was a non-smoker.
I was you know to.
To to actually still be amongst some
fairly entrenched marijuana users
and not to be a smoker was
quite threatening. I think.
I was just allergic test. Some. No.
And you can get your highs
in many many ways you know
that the dancing the blue
knob hall and the dancers
that we used to have a good i
call. Just had to be experienced.
New year's eve in blue know who was
particularly if that fabulous and the year
that. I know i don't know what year
john john and sue fox came with.
Welfare state international but we built
the giant and and had the lanterns
and and and the bonfire.
It was it was wonderful.
And
that was something that's come of nimbin
this is is the celebration the sharing.
Both in births and in death.
We've had deaths in in with children
and other adults and.
And even last year almost
exactly a year ago john
and two fox came to visit
at us here in lismore
and my father had died the
day before they arrived
and they helped me prepare a
celebration of his passing.
Which we held here in the garden and that
was just beautiful. And it was it was.
Moving on from the the
rituals and ceremonies
that we'd had an impact my children know
when they moved in the naming ceremony.
So to celebration.
May be had in this and had
an ism is a hard one.
It's just delightful delightful
delights and earthly delights.
It's how i remember it. And i suppose for
perhaps. Being in the in the mama role.
It was it like my life
was somewhat tempered by
that didn't stop me from dancing my.
My pregnant belly off night after night.
You know. Wonderful night. Amazing men.
Oh oh.
Oh this fern and free and friendship tony.
And sonny and.
John i and.
Mirada indian names aboriginal names.
South american names all sorts
of things flowers trees.
Peter amazing things i can't remember.
The name.
The idea of naming the names of the children
or finding the names of the children.
I was again.
Relating to how how we
felt about where we were.
And perhaps rejection of the citizens
and the johns and the david and so on.
And finding names that had meaning.
Many children
when a md because of the meaning of their
their name because there was a strong.
Indian tibetan american indian influence.
On the spirituality of the people. So people
had you know. Virginity type names or.
Or would his name.
So south american in the environmental
movement led to children having names of
trees and and and animals so.
Perhaps.
Being being interested in and
reclaiming different cultures
and searching for a culture.
I think that we we took him tested out
and checked out all the other cultures
that were not the western white
protestant ethic anything but.
So you know people there
was a south america.
There was the american indian it was the.
The the indian. Tibetan buddhist.
Also it's a different cultures with.
Were examined and looked at and bits were
taken from him but so taken to hear that.
From there that that.
Went up to build the culture
that's developed in this area
and.
Bring it. For.
Oh yes.
Again from the sublime to the ridiculous
you can only it's like what i was saying
before about having to go all the way i
mean if you look at these sort of you go to
some of these conferences and things
that they have now these set conferences
and and you know that that the big
multinationals and and the banks
and the government and even the
public service have now and you have.
You have a brainstorm. You
know. And in the brainstorm.
They say the wildest ideas you've got you
know all these people get paid thousands
and thousands of dollars for doing these
these consultancies you know letting go
and you know just let your minds
go free of the wildest ideas
and then from there we can find something.
It's only if you let your
mind go free and you let me.
At the ultimate that you get something
solutions. Alternative that he's no debt.
You know. Conferences and
your consultants no live.
Doing that things like you know. We which
we are allowed to to push the limits.
You know because it's only
by pushing the limits
that you actually find something
otherwise you live in mediocrity if you.
You know it's sort of like if you don't.
If you don't go out a little bit further.
You're not going to see the view.
I can't think of any favorites. I mean.
Jenny delsea recon turn.
Hadn't thought about.
Fun in the ministry. Some of the houses.
I mean when you're talking about pushing
the limits it's some of the houses
that people built you know
from. From tepees to.
To houses made out of.
Aluminium plates from printed.
Recycling you know just the amazing things
that people could do it with cycling.
Peter pedals and his and his
bicycle technology you know.
The idea of you know making
smoothies on a bicycle.
Pedal power.
Those those things then can be refined
and turned into two really usable things.
People do was it was a guy who used to go
around the streets and wearing dresses
and hats from st vinnies and made
made puppets from from twig.
And i can't remember his name.
I mean he was he was excentric campus
but he was he told wonderful stories
and then people know.
And and allow that space for
for for telling the story.
The community.
You know just just oh you can't have all
these people from all these different
groups and things coming
together and living.
Successfully and people have done it.
For a great.
I mean i mean areas
and so one of the attributes of an aries
is is to be pioneering to be in on the
ground floor of the things and
that was what i was i did a lot
and then been that they're going to
that's what i did a lot in limbo.
And was involved in the setting up of
a number of the the community groups
that are organizations activities
that are still happening.
We talked about birth and beyond.
And i was involved in that
and very early days i was involved
in the home builders association in
my my female capacity.
In the community school i was my my
children were some of the first first
children to go to the community school.
And was was involved in the various committees
that we set up to to get that going.
The co-anchor pre-school which isn't nimbin
but still run on in the same sort of.
Lines. And yeah. So a lot of
the things that went on there.
I i like to be i was involved in
like to think that i was there and
that the early days. I've i've. I helped.
Two has is. The first house
with i was on shad land.
Artillery in iraq with some dear friend
that in elsbeth who i
first met in katmandu
that all the world meets in them been to.
And marcus and i built
that house together.
And it was made entirely
of recycled materials.
And was very beautiful
and made ideas like we used
the poles were made from.
Dead trees and.
We thought that because the dead trees
had all been eaten up by white ants
that we wouldn't have any problems with
white ants so we built the house with a
pole straight into the ground not
wanting to use chemicals or the like.
And the white ants thought
this was just wonderful.
And so they used this is their
channels to go to to build up and
and eat every other bit of the house and.
Eventually sort of went back to the
earth it was a biodegradable house.
And it was exquisite it was just
like a hansel and gretel house
and covered in vines and
my babies who up there.
It was beautiful and the other house
that i built.
Were is on my own title in
a village in a community
environment there and that has i designed.
I did all the convincing when i
purchased the land. I did that myself.
I designed it. I did the plans.
I had the services of a builder
to do a lot of the work.
And every morning before i went
to work in the public service.
I used to get up six o'clock and
work on the house for two hours
and then go to work and then come home in
the evenings and work on it. Again. So.
Yeah i've built.
I've built a lot of that house too and
other people came and helped as well
and we had working b
and and it was lovely.
Your work.
I guess.
The challenges for the area is to find
creative responses to the unemployment
program problem.
The challenge is to not be
overwhelmed by despair.
The challenge is to maintain heart
for me is to maintain heart
in a bureaucracy which
is fairly heartless.
So we have very very
high unemployment here
and.
I see that as a possibility
with creative responses to
that situation to again keep
the spirit of aquarius going
and finding new ways of doing things and.
And the department is is is responding.
I've been involved in the training and
employment of people in the birthing
and yogurt yoga training.
In permaculture in organic farming.
There are people making training
and setting up an incubator
business in recycled and.
Found timbers to make furniture.
Hopefully enterprises like.
The rainbow power company will
will grow in a. Other areas too.
So yeah it's it's also being
being.
A sort of a medium a mediator
between the bureaucracies.
Which are struggling to come to terms with
the ideas of the alternative lifestyle
and they and other
people in this area too.
And therefore and their
unemployment problem. Situation.
Maybe unemployment can be turned
into something other than a problem.
For you.
I'm i'm struggling against the
use of the at the word hope.
Because it kind of smacks of no hope.
So my my vision my my
optimism for nimbin is
that it will learn go on learning from its
export are experience.
That the nimbin is not seen as just being
them thin but is more than the name
and so there's an indian village
in the nimbin community
and then aquarius goes beyond that.
That the children that have
grown up in and around nimbin.
Will be able to hold in their hearts
and they will they they
will they will always have
that even if they they set it aside for
a time they were always having the
nimbin experienced an embittered
growing in their hearts
and they will always be very special
and very different as a result of it.
So that that nimbin will will grow.
That nimbin will be able to. To. Two.
Move into the 21st century with
the best of what we've learned
and to deal in.
A compassionate and heart
filled way with the problems
and to acknowledge its shadow side.
But to to grow. My pleasure.
When i saw people.